♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to the news.
Happy New Year, everyone!
Tonight is our first show
of 2023.
It was going to be yesterday,
but I was on Southwest, so.
[ Laughter ]
The House held its vote today
to elect a new speaker
and went to multiple ballots
for the first time in 100 years.
It's the moment every member
of Congress fears --
having to work longer hours.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set tomorrow
to promote
the bipartisan infrastructure
bill at an event in Kentucky
with Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell.
That's right, America's
crumbling infrastructure
is going to promote the
bipartisan infrastructure bill.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC is warning
that a new variant
of the Omicron strain
of coronavirus
has nearly doubled
over the past week,
so it looks like COVID
is the only thing
that's actually doing
new year, new me.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans took control today
of the House of Representatives
for the first time
in four years.
Well, the first
legal time in four years.
[ Laughter ]
George Santos was sworn in today
as a member
of the House of Representatives
in the state of New York
and, not as he
originally claimed,
Pandora.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
We had a moment backstage.
We were like,
"Do we think everybody's
up to speed on the
George Santos story?"
[ Laughter ]
Been two weeks.
Everybody's with family.
They're not going to be reading
the news every day.
And now we know.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys know "Avatar"
came out?
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
was reportedly DJing
on his iPad
at Mar-A-Lago last week...
[ Laughter ]
...and played Celine Dion's
"My Heart Will Go On."
[ Laughter ]
Wow, the guy definitely knows
how to get a party started.
[ Laughter ]
What'd he play at midnight,
"Everybody Hurts" by R.E.M.?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Of course,
no one hurts more than I do.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Trump was DJing on his iPad
last week at Mar-A-Lago
and I think the legal bills
are piling up for him
because every song was followed
by a Spotify ad.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
Just a few quick words
from my friends at Spotify.
[ Laughter ]
According
to newly released testimony,
former First Lady Melania Trump
was upset
that Rudy Giuliani was allowed
inside the White House residence
and was worried about him seeing
her wearing a bathrobe.
Or, 1,000 times more likely,
her seeing him in one.
[ Laughter ]
New York state's first licensed
marijuana store opened last week
in Manhattan at 4:20 p.m.,
and it must be good weed
because it was supposed to open
at 10:00 a.m.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, yesterday was
National 55 Mile Per Hour
Speed Limit Day,
or, as it's called
in New Jersey,
the texting lane.
[ Laughter ]
House Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy failed to secure
enough votes to ascend
to the Speakership today
after a fifth ballot.
Incidentally, a fifth is also
what he drank during the vote.
[ Laughter ]
"Son of a gun."
20 House Republicans voted
against GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy
during today's fifth
Speaker ballot.
God, you guys can't even have
a red wave amongst yourselves.
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that President Biden has
no plans to intervene
in the House Speaker election
after Republican Kevin McCarthy
failed to secure enough votes
during the second ballot
to ascend to the Speakership,
at least not until it stops
being hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
During his inaugural address
yesterday,
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
criticized Democrats' agenda
and said, quote, "Florida
is where woke goes to die."
In fact,
it's where
everything goes to die.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, to be fair.
According to newly released
Congressional testimony,
ex-White House adviser
Kellyanne Conway said
that former President Trump
is afraid
of former First Lady
Melania Trump.
Well, she is an immigrant.
[ Laughter ]
Disgraced...
Disgraced cryptocurrency
exchange founder
Sam Bankman-Fried pleaded
not guilty yesterday
in federal court
on a series of charges
including money laundering,
which from the looks of him
may be the only thing
he's ever laundered.
[ Laughter ]
The Southwest Airlines
pilot union
published a letter yesterday
denouncing the carrier's
leadership and said
the company was turning
into a cult.
Even worse, they only give you
half a Kool-Aid.
[ Laughter ]
Anytime you can make a joke
both about how small
the beverage servings are
on airlines
and Jonestown...
[ Laughter ]
...comedy gold.
A woman in West Virginia
recently had her wallet
returned to her
nearly 55 years after she
lost it at a high school dance.
"That's not all she lost,"
said her 54-year-old daughter.
[ Laughter ]
You guys did the math
very quickly.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of International
Delight coffee creamer
have announced they will release
a new flavor
inspired by the Central Perk
coffee shop on "Friends."
Although, I don't know
if you can call vanilla "new."
[ Laughter ]
Two people in Florida
were arrested recently
after one of them allegedly
called 911
to get help moving items
from a home
they were burglarizing.
But to be fair,
the police did help.
[ Laughter ]
It's a jail cell.
When you put too much
nice furniture in a jail cell,
it just looks like a studio
apartment in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
Like, everybody saw that,
they were like, "Well, ehhh..."
[ Laughter ]
"You say I get
three meals a day?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Idaho
recently set
a Guinness World Record
after stomping 100 balloons
in 22.38 seconds.
It was for Most Ruined
Birthday Party.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said yesterday
that he will travel next week
to the southern border
for the first time
since taking office.
When asked if it was dangerous,
the Secret Service said,
"A little, but we don't think
he'll actually try to escape."
[ Laughter ]
The House of Representatives
adjourned last night
after a sixth round of voting
for House Speaker
and reconvened today at noon.
Because nothing says
"we're working hard
to solve this problem"
like starting at noon.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
reportedly called
House Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy on Monday night
ahead of the Speaker vote
and urged him to accept all
of the Freedom Caucus's demands.
But unfortunately
McCarthy told him
hair gel in the water fountains
wasn't feasible.
[ Laughter ]
Goldman Sachs this week
ended its free coffee perk
for employees, which is weird,
because there are still
piles of sugar on the desks?
[ Audience ohs, laughs ]
A federal appeals court ruled --
[ Light laughter ]
A federal appeals court
ruled last week
that a teacher
in Washington State
who wore a MAGA hat to school
was protected
by the 1st Amendment.
"Cool,"
said one of his students.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
nearly half of American workers
are planning to look for a
new job in the next six months.
And some will still be looking
for the same one.
[ Laughter ]
The "New York Post"
recently launched a contest
for high school students to win
a chance to publish an article,
and it was a reminder...
you cannot trust Hannah R.
with anything.
[ Laughter ]
A baby gear start-up company
this week unveiled
a $3,300 self-driving stroller.
Previously, all the self-driving
strollers on the market
only worked on hills.
[ Laughter ]
Mechan--
[ Laughs ]
Mechanics at
a Florida car dealership
recently found a rabbit
trapped in the vehicle's motor
while doing an oil change.
Said the mechanic, "So, that's
gonna be at least another $750,
and I can't even
get another rabbit here
until late next week."
[ Laughter ]
Today was
National Screenwriters Day.
They spent it --
interior -- Starbucks --
pretending to work.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was also
National Bird Day.
Or, as they call it
in New Jersey,
a turn signal.
You guys...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...that was the monologue.
♪♪